certainly hope in the pandemic fight  here in nevada but there is still a lot  of  pain in our community three square food  bank is asking for your help to help  fight  childhood hunger food insecurity affects  one in four  children here in southern nevada through  the month of may every donation to three  square is going to be matched by nevada  gold mines  and the envy energy foundation it's the  annual bag  childhood hunger campaign it's our ramp  up toward the summer when we know so  many children are  more food insecure not having daily  meals in school so this is a wonderful  opportunity for some  generous corporate friends to match your  donation so that  every dollar you give for childhood  hunger  actually gets doubled you can donate  online  at threesquare.org and on that website  you can also find resources if you  need help with the emergency food  pantries that are available around the  valley